it is from time to time at this very
moment I've been reading a lot of anne
carson and a lot of an italian poet
named Valerio my greyle and those are my
two poets at the moment but there's
always a handful that I've refer to and
there's the old ones one of the poems
I'm going to read is about all my
masters
it's the most recent home I have which
makes it fun to read it's called the
foundation watch me I'm running watch me
I'm dancing I'm air the building I used
to live in has been raised and I'm
skipping hopping two-footed Lee leaping
across the blocks bricks slabs of
concrete plaster and other unnameable
junk or nameable really if you look at
the raikage closely here for instance
the shattered I beam is the Bible and
this chunk of mortar play-doh the mortar
of mind also in pieces and pieces in me
anyway in my mind Aristotle and
Nietzsche Freud and Camus and Boober and
Christ even that year of reading
Paradise Lost when I thought hell why
not but that fracture to Kierkegaard
Hagel and comp and golf Minh and marks
all heaped in the foundation and I sped
through so often that now I have it by
heart can run Dansby air not think of
the spew of intellectual dust I scuffed
up when in my hardly broken in boots I
first clumped through the sanctums of
Buddhism Taoism zen and the Areopagus
whose entire text I typed out my God why
I didn't care i just kept bumping my
head on the lentils Einstein the
Gnostics Kabbalah st. this and st. that
watch me again now because I'm not alone
in my dancing my being air I'm with my
poets my Rilke my Yates were leaping
together through the debris a jumble of
rack but my Keats floats across it my
Herbert and done my canal my bishop and
Blake or soaring across it my frost
Baudelaire my Dickinson Lowell and
larkin and my giants my Whitman my
Shakespeare my Dante and Homer they were
the steel the scouring as I was the
savin sand sages
at the time I hardly knew it but vallejo
was there all along and my Sydney and
Shelley my Coleridge and Hopkins there
all along with their music which is why
I can world through the rubble of
everything else the philosophizing and
theories the thesis and anti and syn all
I believe must be what meanings were
made of when really it was the singing
the quiring the cadence the lull of the
vowels the chrome aticle consonant
clatter watch me again I haven't landed
i'm hovering here over the fragments the
remnants the splinters and shards my
poets are with me my sorors my skimmers
my scanners aloft on their song in the
runes they're jubilant song of the ruins
actually the genesis of that is sort of
interesting when I was a kid in Newark
next to the apartment house where we
lived a little apartment house there was
a building that had fallen down or had
never been built and the foundation was
there and it had become a dump for
various rubble stuff building Robo and I
must have been six or seven and I would
practice running across it until I could
just go full speed across it and I'd
always wanted to write a poem about that
and it took 65 years and then there was
the pound which is not the poem I would
have thought would have come from
you